tras 12 años de suspensión Siria es
readmitida en la liga árabe la decisión
fue tomada a Puerta cerrada por los
ministros de exteriores de los países
miembros del organismo el reingreso vino
acompañado entre otros aspectos de un
llamado de atención a los actores del
conflicto interno sidio para resolver la
crisis
es necesario defender el concepto de una
patria integral y segura y el
cumplimiento de cada uno de los
componentes del gobierno sirio las
fuerzas nacionales la comunidad
internacional y los países interesados
con sus obligaciones hacia los demás
para que Siria vuelva a los sirios
unificada estable e independiente
la resolución no contó con un respaldo
unánime varios estados entre ellos Qatar
se oponen a una reapertura con Damasco
sin tener sobre la mesa una solución
política en este sentido se creará una
comisión conformada por varias naciones
y el secretario general de la liga para
buscar soluciones a la guerra civil
el regreso de Siria es el comienzo de un
movimiento no el final la dirección de
la resolución de la crisis llevará
tiempo para que se apliquen los
procedimientos será gradual la tarea de
esta comisión es hacer seguimientos de
estos procedimientos el gobierno sirio
reaccionó con un pedido el desarrollo de
un enfoque efectivo basado sobre el
respeto mutuo entre los estados miembros
de la liga árabe Siria fue expulsada en
el año 2011 tras la represión de las
fuerzas del orden contra las protestas
que pedían un cambio de gobierno
los manifestantes reclamaban El Fin Del
mandato de la familia al azar tras 40
años en el poder